[Music]
a lot of people think the big news
stories today are the snowstorm that's
hitting the midwest or the looming
federal budget cuts
but
judging by local news there's apparently
an even bigger story that's sweeping the
nation right now check it out well if
you filled up your gas tank lately then
you don't need us to tell you that gas
prices are back on the rise you don't
need us to tell you that gas prices are
back on the rise you don't need us to
tell you the gas prices are back on the
rise you don't need us to tell you that
gas prices are back on the rise and you
don't need us to tell you that gas
prices are back on the rise you don't
need us to tell you that gas prices are
back on the rise so you don't need
us to tell you the gas prices are back
on the road you don't need us to tell
you that gas prices are back on the ride
you don't need us to tell you gas prices
are back on the rise you don't need us
to tell you that gas prices are back on
the rise you don't need us to tell you
that gas prices are back on the rise
well you don't need us to tell you gas
prices are back on the rock but you
don't need us to tell you that gas
sponsors are back on the rise you don't
need us to tell you gas prices are on
the rise i know
[Applause]
that's unbelievable
that's kind of scary i really think
what a coincidence yeah